plus d'un mois et demi après le coup de
force du président kaïs saïd autant de
la lutte anti-corruption la tunisie est
toujours enlisé dans une grave crise
politique
luge et était à la puissante centrale
syndicale qui a soutenu le chef de
l'état dans son projet de changement
semble perdre patience la correspondance
à tunis sinivassin chebbi c'est un
communiqué qui résonne comme un coup de
pression celui de la puissante centrale
syndicale tunisienne élus gtt au
président kaïs sayed et l'union générale
tunisienne du travail premier syndicat
du pays avaient dès le 25 juillet
apporté son soutien au président de la
république alors de son coup de force
mais voilà qu'un mois et demi plus tard
tout comme de nombreux tunisiens du gtt
commence à s'impatienter dans un
communiqué est publié hier le bureau
exécutif de l'ugtt et a de nouveau
appelé à la formation d'un nouveau
gouvernement restreint ainsi qu'à la fin
des mesures exceptionnelles et à la mise
en place d'une gouvernance basée sur une
légitimité populaire écouter il est
urgent d'accélérer la formation d'un
gouvernement restreint avec pour rôle de
traiter les dossiers économiques sociaux
et sanitaires de garantir la continuité
de l'état et de mettre à exécution de
ces engagements tout retard en la
matière mène à l'approfondissement de la
crise au démantèlement de l'état et en
menacent l'existence la centrale
syndicale a notamment insisté sur
l'importance du dialogue social en
tunisie et a rappelé les acquis de la
révolution notamment par la même
occasion la nécessité d'éviter le
recours à la justice militaire en ce qui
concerne les affaires civiles alors que
de nombreux partis politiques avocats ou
encore membres de la société civile ont
dénoncé le projet de réforme de la
constitution visage et pour le chef de
l'état et du gtt semble ne plus pouvoir
caché son inquiétude face à un cahier ça
y est bien décidé à faire cavalier seul
faisant fi de toute critique ou menace
du côté de carthage les annonces
officielles se font rares le conseiller
à la présidence de la république oui
l'ajam a laissé entendre sur une chaîne
de télévision étrangère quel nouveau
gouvernement pourrait être annoncé dans
les prochains